bienvenue dans la plus extraordinaire et
inoubliable expérience à découvrir sur
notre planète
des milliers de visiteurs chaque mois
des centaines de millions de dollars par
an le volcan se réveille mais s'il me
dit que le volcan est sûre alors c'est
qu'il l'est on ne risque plus rien
faites moi confiance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
alors cette grotte et l'a jamais exploré
le puits des sons apic près on se
retrouve en bas pour soi savez avec une
musique
[Applaudissements]
incroyable
mais c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
le club doit être ancrée
quelqu'un a dû réseau ici personne va
falloir nager que ça nous plaît souvent
vous reste groupé et on panique pas
va falloir nager n'oublie pas un petit
détail
rocco défendre leur territoire et nous
lâchera pas tant qu'on sera ici
sur dos
après oui
à
il croit jeune homme bravo ces fameux
merci
la trousse la victoire vous avez beau
dire tu peux aller demain matin à zurich
elle a l'air tout va la jouer facile
vous êtes libre eh oui
[Musique]
si vous tenez une fois
je suis consciente a pas tout ce que tu
veux
quelque chose avec un enfant sera
différée partir d'ici
c'est quasiment ce tour et c'est vrai
aussi prendre des pâtes fournel
sais tu fais tu pour ce petit comme sa
sauce au chinois
[Applaudissements]
l'endroit parfait pour moi
tiens pas un
[Musique]
minutes et nathan mais pourquoi tu as
fait ça c'est facile à réparer juger un
tournevis dans la voiture envisage une
carrière d'humoriste tu raconte des
blagues et effrayante monter sur scène
j'ai un ami qui a toujours voulu faire
de la comédie mais on avait le meilleur
ami pas idée à quel point je prends la
plupart du temps on aurait dit qu'ils
étaient mariés et j'étais simple
spectatrice
[Musique]
salut les filles et vibrant cheveux
quand tu vois fatigué merci d'être venus
montrer pas ça
la thèse qu'on puisse parler un moment
la combinaison de la maladie de
médicaments va provoquer des réactions
jamais vu avant si je pourrai vous aider
à traverser ça mais moi pour ça j'espère
pas plus que quelques semaines je veux
juste m'assurer que matt su remettre sur
pied près par les dg n'est peut-être que
moi je peux enlever un peu de ce poids
j'espérais que dorénavant tu pourrais
m'appeler grand-maman démoli c'est pas
une réponse qui je t'appelle grand-maman
des mercis et tu veux terminer je
voudrais écrire des lettres aux filles
pour les grandes étapes de leur vie
voilà tu vas me dire quand ça va
commencer il ya rien qui se passe enfin
toute sa vie elle a voulu être grand
maréchal du mardi gras
je me sentais sur scène avec katy perry
se semble assez faisable tu crois est
parti depuis trois mois déjà je croyais
que tu allais est reparti pour quelques
semaines qu'est ce qui a changé
j'ai tout de suite réalisé que personne
pouvait faire ça tout seul je ne crois
pas que tu es en colère parce que j'ai
15 minutes de retard
la maman je crois que tu es en colère
parce que maman est malade
pourquoi t'es dur avec ton père vient de
briser mon corps jetés veut sourire les
gens évitent de me regarder quand il m'a
par la plus belle femme que j'ai jamais
tu le seras toujours
[Musique]
et pas obligés de rester non plus
nicole c'est mon ami aussi ça me fait
plaisir d'être
[Musique]
le monde ne sera plus le même
il faudra qu'on trouve un autre endroit
où habiter
hushovd
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
quoi qu'il arrive je serai toujours
pour te protéger
[Musique]
le vrai nom un sabot puis avec moi elle
mois le retrouver
[Musique]
c'était des séries
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 1969 un chien fut envoyé dans
l'espace
mais un accident le transforma en super
héros maintenant perdu dans un futur où
tout le monde déteste les animaux qu'il
doit trouver un super équipier turbo 4
un chat
je voudrais tellement retrouver mon
maître utilise ses pouvoirs et et demi
désolé tu peux résumer tu n'es pas qu'un
simple chien petit qui les stars tankers
ou quelqu'un veut jouer la balle
stardock et turbo cat prochainement au
cinéma
[Musique]
au bout du quai
deux actionnaires
[Musique]
musique
m
[Musique]
bourhis ignorait comment notre salle
sitôt
[Musique]
c'est ça
à 22 ans
je ne sais pas
sans vidéo
[Musique]
moi
ils doivent avoir
[Musique]
poutine
nos jeunes
cette somme est
ski
nous ratons livre janvier
non
et que en off
[Musique]
j'ai toujours le meilleur qu'on fait
qu'elle faisait là tous ensemble heureux
en bonne santé ce cadeau love peut nous
offrir jusqu'à mes cent vingt ans
je fabule grand chose
[Musique]
j'ai fait pour en arriver
quel c'est toi la star de la famille
j'aurais été la star citait pts
[Musique]
j'adore ce camion
si possible qu'on leur trouve jamais
retrouvé une gamine qui s'évapore sur
une route sans témoin ce mec ne fait pas
d'erreur tu sais où elle est la petite
ça fait 20 ans qu'ils passent entre les
mailles du filet comment on fait pour
coincer un type qui fait pas d'erreur je
suis sûr que ce type a fait d'autres
victimes
je veux la retrouver à tout prix
[Musique]
tu as
je viens j'arrive j'arrive je sors deux
secondes six jeux à l'école c'est comme
ça je vais pas mourir quatre garçons
donc moi je suis un [ __ ] c'est ça
parce que je suis son père et je veux
pas qu'on me coupe les couilles
bah moi je suis sa mère shobaki scoop y
règne je pense que c'est la vie d'un
garçon s'habillant rivasi allait rentrer
à la maison à pied
je veux juste que me guérit bien
une chance qu'ils acceptent comme inès
et ça a pris je suis votre nouveau prof
de français
mercredi elle l'est maintenant
alors c'est toi c'est moi de voir à la
tête de con il y en a toujours une
boulot ce lieu là c'est un endroit des
changes et de respect 3 je parle de toi
tarik doivent noter alors elle moins
courageux teulet si vous pensez à gagner
le respect des élèves c'est raté
j'ai changé quelques méthodes ces deux
bons points comme sa part du boulot
c'est pas bien d'être prof ça fait deux
jours qu'on m'a rien dit il est parti
sans lui s'il m'en irai pas pris
d'affaires il répond pas au téléphone
faut lancer un avis de recherche
on va voir foyers dans votre vie privée
professionnelle mais j'ai rien à cacher
marc espérant que votre mari non plus
[Musique]
marc et des fois on redouble rien très
très belle
on disparaît pas comme ça sans raison
[Musique]
quand le truc vous et surdoué en 62 qi
au potentiel intellectuel hpi on cherche
depuis la 5 et 8 ans tu peux essayer
qui a été embauché par les filles de
france p 7 pas vraiment le fbi
sur ce que je veux dire deux trois coups
quoi mais quoi là-bas vous avait défoncé
la porte en moi je vous soutiens
moralement aller en france et sur les
postes est toujours le meilleur
complémentaires
[Musique]
c'est là tous ensemble heureux en bonne
santé ce qu'elles doivent pas nous
offrir jusqu'à mes cent vingt ans
je fais avec grand chose
[Musique]
quand j'ai fait pour en arriver
quel c'est toi la star de la famille
d'ange aurait été la star citait peter
[Musique]
j'adore cette famille
je me suis forgé je me suis vengé du
cher ami chez qui n'avait son fils
je l'étranglé hijri j'étais à la vologne
ma vengeance et crêtes
à deux clans les pros la roche sont
hantées questionner les progrès ce
tronçon entier la revue
pardonne pas trois jours pour comprendre
que christine l'édile corbeau ni
l'assassin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]